patients should know when hospitals are
talking about men or
women and we shouldn't get bullied
people are waking up on all sides of
this and uh one of the I think bigger
problems that we have right now is that
a lot of the people waking up have been
the very same people who have ushered in
so much of this stuff we see this all
the time right like so a lot of the
Liberals uh who say nothing as this is
going on and when people five years ago
were screaming about this they were
saying you're trans phobes and bigots
then it starts sort of arriving at their
door and they kind of come around now I
suppose better late than ever but this
this is an interesting video uh because
this is bursting forth not just in the
United States it's happening all over
Western society as you know it's
interesting that it keeps happening in
Western Society isn't that bizarre uh
but here is a video of UK prime minister
Rishi sunak and he's kind of coming
around to biological reality hot diggity
Dam we are going to change this country
and that means life means life now that
shouldn't be a controversial position
the vast majority of hardworking people
agree with it and it also shouldn't be
controversial for parents to know what
their children are being taught in
school about relationships patients
should know when hospitals are talking
about men or women and we shouldn't get
bullied wow UK prime minister sunak
apparently a big Ronda santis guy right
parents should know what's going on we
should accept biological reality uh
these are things that should not be
debated anymore like yeah a bunch of us
that were screaming about all of this
stuff and warning that all these weird
things were a coming and by the way
there are more weird things a coming
because it never stops right it never
stops there will be something weird
after this but have no doubt the the
radical left that exists in the UK and
they have a very strong radical left
they're maybe not quite as like sort of
ubiquitous in every part of society as
we have here but they will come after
Rishi sunak there there's no doubt about
that